si regga voi non potete cresce io allora
quando registro gli horror spengo tutte
le luci della casa tutte ma voi non
potete capire la targa che ciò in questo
preciso momento va bene tutti ragazzi e
benvenute questo video spero che i
fantasmi non mi sento che sono fa vj
oggi siamo tornati su 3 da workshop
[ __ ] che botta ecco più o meno
succedeva niente ma la madonna manco
parco sono cascato 18 ragazzi chi è che
ha aperto la porta c'è ancora chitarra
ma vi faccio un concertino lega s'è
mosso un tavolo cazzo pregassimo assunta
vi giuro che si è mosso un tavolo e l'ho
visto dove se non volevi mangiare in
casa me lo dicevi prima andavamo al
ristorante ca zzo sposti gli abili a dai
[ __ ] via dei [ __ ] bravi ma
ripensandoci va bene mangiare a casa e
chiesto sta succedendo legati preciso
che mi sta inquietando abbastanza che
cazzo per chiedermi maltrattarmi gatti
così all'improvviso ma perché usata
fatto sto povero cristo di un gattino
ma ce l'hai la patente zio non è che
buttiamo giù le moto così e non puoi
guidare con 50 euro di multa anzi anche
di più
l'interferenza lega dov'è dove ca ta
dove l'ho beccata senza sapere dove mi
spiegate cosa cazzo è successo regala
cosa ho fotografato ok ma non mi
travasarla 4 grazie al mitico a vero
perfetto perfetto cazzo sì ma liberato
il passaggio vai vai veloce veloce prima
che ricomponga tutto è brava continua la
cia le sedie bravo così io ormai aveva
quando ho visto il tipo nello specchio
c'è la fobia del disco non mi guarderò
nello specchio manco nella vita reale io
da sola e vai vai posso entrare in
questa porta senza i misfatti fuori
grazie è molto gentile perfetto e uscire
senza che qualcuno mi stupri no niente
ci sono delle sedie ci sono
continuamente degli specchi e quindi mi
devo pagare in mano e lo so già ragazzi
la madonna che foto famiglia la donna
che allo specchio si vede più vecchia si
no io non mi vedo allo specchio cosa
cazzo succede ma non era uno specchio
merda penso associazioni specchio che mi
sono confuso invece era una presa per il
culo cosa ho trovato una chiave grande
non so cosa mi serve ma va bene buono a
sapersi
adesso lo vedo lo specchio perché prima
no adesso non torno più indietro qual è
il problema spiega melo ma salve ragazzi
posso deliziarvi con una fotografia ci
sono due persone sedute nello specchio
esattamente qui a san luis fu chi cazzo
sareste voi ve lo spiegate come torna
indietro non l'ho spiegato non ho capito
il senso julia
cala [ __ ] [ __ ] forchia thin man
cristiano non può fotografare delle cose
che degli specchi
ok hai mal di testa ma che cazzo una
chaval di testa perché fotografa degli
specchi ma mi sembra normale sta roba
ma che cazzo di per disse non sono
specchi sono cornici nel muro non ho
veramente capito sta roba ma corrotto
uno specchio
anzi soprattutto bene o scassato
dispetti bevevano e sono io sono un
vandalo usando le faccio io spacco
specchi nel tempo libero è normale
usciamo di qua perché già mi sta venendo
l'asl ansia doveva c'è una tipa
paranormale che sposta le gli oggetti
non vorrei mai che si incazza sé perché
ho spaccato nello specchio
adesso è tutto in ordine prima ero la
merda che non si poteva ancora la roba
che veniva sbattuto per aria adesso no
cioè tranquillo ma ma ecco che è questa
qua la tipa [ __ ] che dicevo prima da un
assedio sopracciglia che manco na qui è
una roba del tipo cazzola qualche
domanda è la lite la merda ancora non ho
capito dopo c'era un insetto sul muro e
non ciò la chiappa moschee cup tu che
sei sul muro ascoltami dove l'ho preso
l'ho preso l'ho colpito può colpire
fatemi uscire
fatemi uscire cazzo no è chiuso ma certo
ascolta sta qui dove è uno stronzo
regalano tutto capitana [ __ ] tua mamma
non ci non ci stiamo veramente capendo
che cazzo distanza è prima cosa proprio
secondo no dal soffitto no per l'amor di
dio come faccio prendo io
lo vedi questo sì no no [ __ ] eccoli
capire che i cani se vuoi li adotti ma
non così cioè non è che puoi venire da
me scodinzolando non c'ho le crocchette
di darti e scott a 0 capiamoci che sta
succedendo lo stesso miur di ragazzi si
sta crepando tutto nella stanza non so
se è normale però dove quello riecco
maledetto idiota rara e bravo stretch a
kaarst race ai miei piedi lurido un odio
scusate chimica ebbe bruttissimo scorta
zio ben felici perché alla stanza così
taccia il mac store oppure 2 o dio santo
che cosa madonna esorcismo dove dove non
lo vedo cazzo possiamo stare con tutta
la vita volendo l'ho preso
non c'è che pacchia è stato rotto uno
specchio
almeno non c'è un agente che mi salta
addosso potrebbe essere un valore
positivo questo ragazzi è stato
parecchio istruttivo credetemi cielo ho
imparato ad addestrare un cane
credo che sia la stessa cosa ha dato le
scale con complimenti per le pulizie
alle scale ragazzi c'è veramente figo e
la stanza di 50 sfumature di grigio
organismi mi frusta vestas trans no
abbassa si specchi ti prego perché ti
devi guardare allo specchio che sei già
che esce la madama dalla dietro perché
ma perché devo fare ste cagate riga
perché questa qui quali problemi che
affliggono figlia mini no non ti toccare
per favore a me five prendi questo gioco
vietato non è mino a ti alzi già cosa fa
telecom usa lo sapevo io che c'era una
parrucchiera nascosta dietro sapevamo
nomi italiani che baila permanente zia
sono 20 euro facciamo 5 euro perché ti
sta simpatica inutile che mi abbracci
che ti denuncio cazzo del cazzo sei
molto meno abbronzata nello specchio
ok gara si no il massaggio shiatsu cosa
che come ragazzi le droghe
le droghe pesanti fanno questo rega è
stato ritmo amica mia io devo dormire da
sola a casa mia adesso per carità di
dire né bene un po
voglio più dormire da solo a caso se
chiamo qualcuno dormite con me grazie a
questa si risveglia cazzo in mezzo alla
strada così il caso va bene dove stiamo
rega cos'è nuova beh ma questo
all'inizio era la scuola del primo atto
quando è finito l'ato1 dato primo noi
siamo entrati in questa scuola qualcosa
ho fatto fino adesso cioè mi sono
trastullato a terra era un sogno tutto
un sogno che si è messa a correre cosa
corradi che c'è gente che ti stupra la
polizia sei serio c'è veramente dopo
vuoi dirmi che dopo questo bordello
arrivata la pula ma come la cosa ma
veramente ma sei serio cioè dopo tutto
sto casino arrivata la polizia e dovete
farlo capire con un mezzo fumetto gente
che ha tentato di stuprare mi gente che
ha tentato di attaccarsi a matt ipoteca
maniaci che mi seguivano mi spintonavano
gente che tentava di diventare il mio
cane no hanno investito la tiziana vabbè
ancora quella rossa riddick azioni che è
rimasto il segno dello pneumatico sulla
faccia
vabbè si vede di queste cose giuste e
finito così e fini è finito io rivoglio
del tempo della mia vita indietro vi
prego non voglio più vedere una roba del
genere in vita mia devo prendermela con
qualcuno amiri di mastura ti ucciderò
mentre d'oro ragazzi è finito le pile
l'atto 2 d 3 doubt è stato molto de di
fitch che un'altra altra roba c'era
prima
ma chi è rimasto che i ragazzi ci è
rimasto qualcuno chiuso in eccesso ma
sii serio e finisce così va bene
in finale i ragazzi non ci mettete tanto
quando state al cesso perché potrebbero
succedere eventi spiacevoli questa la
morale di tre doubt credo con ragazzi ha
concluso che l'episodio di tre out l'ato
2 finisce qui e spero che vino vi sia
piaciuto che off a 6 di ragazzi seguito
è piaciuto al sotto momento mi piace
anche la passione facebook e come non i
video trovato nella descrizione se
volessi di sette decimi il diavolo
prossimo nido
le ragazze
[Musica]